it's springtime you're outside more it
is time for sunscreen but stay away from
the chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below
we start today not with a profile in
Courage but with a profile in cowardice
and the guy's name is Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis has come up with the most
squirrely I mean we're talking nuttier
than squirrel poop excuse the metaphor
uh the squirreliest way to avoid
answering a very simple question did
failed twice indicted twice impeached
former president Donald Trump violate
the peaceful transfer of power which was
almost I guess we could say they tried
to stop on January 6 2021
and Ron DeSantis comes up with an answer
that is it's so stupid it's almost
laughable and something very strange is
going on with my hair as you can see and
I I really do apologize to the audience
for that continued issues
um he says I wasn't in Washington DC on
January 6th so I I don't really know
what happened oh did
we'll we'll get back to that we'll take
a listen to this
do you believe that Trump violated the
peaceful transfer of power a key
principle that of American democracy
that we must uphold are you in high
school
uh yeah where do you go to school you go
around here
uh Vermont I live in New Hampshire oh
okay so you've been from Vermont well
thank you for the question so here's
what I know
if this election is about Biden's
failures and our vision for the future
we are going to win if it's about
relitigating things that happen two
three years ago we're gonna lose and so
by the way all Ron DeSantis is doing is
relitigating covid and talking about how
he was so much better than Trump on
covet so even so he's already lying but
then we're getting to the real Whopper I
can tell you this
tell us why
[Applause]
I can tell you this
I can point you to
Tallahassee Florida on I believe January
5th 2023 uh we had a transition of power
from my first Administration to my
second because I noticed that this is
completely unrelated to the question one
re-election in a historic fashion and at
the end of the day you know we need to
win and we need to get this done so uh I
wasn't anywhere near Washington that day
I have nothing to do with what happened
that day obviously I didn't enjoy seeing
you know what would happen but we've got
to go forward on that remember the
question wasn't were you in DC or did
you have anything to do with it the
question was will you actually denounce
what Donald Trump did it's a cowardly
cop-out to say I didn't enjoy seeing
what happened Well Ron didn't enjoy it
and I didn't enjoy it but I'm willing to
say Trump was at least partially
responsible for what took place by
inciting his followers Ron DeSantis
isn't willing to say that this this is
the I hate to use the term the Trump
term this is a low energy
cowardly way to run a campaign if you're
actually going to make the case that
you're the better choice than Trump
on all fronts you're going to say I
never would have said the things Trump
said because any sensible person would
realize how some of his followers would
take it and I wouldn't want that
responsibility on my shoulders I will
govern in a different way I would never
do such a thing and by the way I'm also
better on policy but instead DeSantis
knows he sees the numbers this is all a
numbers game in order to have a shot
at winning the primary DeSantis knows he
either needs to dramatically increase
Republican primary turnout which it just
doesn't seem like it's going to happen
or he needs to take some of Trump's
current support because Trump's already
polling 52 percent and DeSantis is
calculating I can't take Trump's support
from his hardcore supporters by saying
he was responsible for the riots I can't
do it they're it's not going to work so
instead DeSantis is taking the Cowardly
way out saying he didn't like what
happened and uh that people should vote
for him and if Trump gets indicted a
third or fourth time and it becomes so
chaotic that he can't even run DeSantis
will just be there
for some Mega people to support him I
don't think it's going to work I don't
think it's going to work at all by the
way here's one other clip from this
event while at the same campaign event
in New Hampshire
DeSantis says what Trump did wrong
wasn't to say lock up Hillary it was to
stop saying I remember these rallies in
2016. it was exciting yeah drain the
swamp I also remember lock her up lock
her up right and then two weeks after
the election oh don't forget about it
forget I ever said that no no no one
thing you'll get from me if I tell you
I'm going to do something I'm not just
saying that for an election right and
there are promises I could make that may
help me marginally politically that I
don't know that I could that I could
necessarily follow through on so I will
not make that Ron DeSantis is saying the
problem with Trump wasn't that he said
lock up Hillary remember
no evidence of crimes no indictment no
conviction but they oh we're for Law and
Order but you have no reason to lock up
Hillary de Santa says the problem wasn't
that Trump said Locker up the problem
was that he stopped saying it and that
he didn't do it this guy is as dangerous
as Trump he's exposing it every single
day also in New Hampshire was not only
Ron Des Sanctus but it was also Donald
Trump in New Hampshire Trump gave a
speech which we will look at but I don't
remember if this was before or after the
speech Donald Trump was confronted about
the leaked crime tape now I don't even
know that we should call it a leaked
audio tape it's a leaked crime tape in
which Trump confirms yeah he knew the
documents were classified he knew he
didn't declassify them he knew he was no
longer the president and he still showed
them to people it is evidence of Trump's
crimes and it is not vaguely of Trump's
crimes he might be charged with
it's evidence of Trump's crimes that he
has already been charged with and and
indicted for Trump is asked about the
leaked audio tape and he says honestly I
don't even know how to explain what he
says he just basically malfunctions here
and says I did nothing wrong
we did absolutely nothing wrong this is
just another hoax it's called Uh I would
say election interference more than
anything else it's a disgrace that they
can do it next question but everything
was fine we did nothing wrong and
everybody knows it
here's a sample of that newly released
audio from two years ago
I was just saying because we were
talking about it and you know he said he
wanted to attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably right
yeah last week with our colleague Brett
Baer the former president insisted that
document did not exist
there was no document that was a massive
amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things and
it may have been held up or may not but
that was not a document I didn't have a
document per se okay it wasn't a
document per se so listen that's Fox
News first of all notable that even Fox
News now they they realize that it is an
incoherent string of lies that conflict
with each other he says to Brett Baier
there were no documents in the recording
he says here's documents then he says it
was fine to show the documents but
because I could declassify them but in
the recording he says they clearly
weren't uh you know it's it's all a mess
and Trump's brain seems to be
functioning so poorly that he's lost an
understanding of what words even mean at
this point what does hoax mean at this
point what what does it mean that it is
a hoax there is a an audio recording is
he saying it's doctored is he saying the
words he uses in the video no longer
have meaning and of course if you just
sit back and think about all of the
conflicting things that have been said
you start to wonder listen don't you
understand guys the tape is a hoax he
had the documents but he had the right
to because he Declassified them except
he says on the recording he didn't
declassify them but the documents were
planted and it's not a crime anyway and
also there were no documents why won't
you just accept that why is it you will
just insist on going after this guy the
biggest victim in the world the most
honest man in political history why
won't you accept the seven different
conflicting explanations about what he
did what he had and what he said and if
you think that this moment when he was
interviewed before or after the speech
was bad you have to see the actual
speech that he gave Donald Trump
spiraling rambling incoherently in New
Hampshire yesterday in front of a mostly
dead silent crowd there were like three
or four moments in the entire rambling
speech where the crowd seemed to come to
life rattled to Life by either
transphobic or otherwise horrifying
comments from Trump otherwise sitting
there like statues I when I went to the
Louvre in Paris the statues showed more
signs of life than this crowd in New
Hampshire yesterday for Donald Trump
here Trump tries to shift the attention
away from his own crimes and attacks Joe
Biden who is Catholic
of wanting to go after Catholics think
about that of all the things you could
make up about Joe Biden Joe Biden is
unique in terms of presidential history
in that he's one of the very few
presidents that is Catholic John F
Kennedy was Catholic it might just be uh
Biden and and JFK who have been our
Catholic presidents but uh Trump says oh
he's going to go after Catholics what
what evidence do you have of that the
Marxist prosecutors who release rapists
and murderers well
persecuting conservatives and by the way
I understand that the audio is a
disaster it must have been antifa
running audio but that's that's an issue
that's not our issue that's the uh
that's the tape here people of religion
Catholics how about Catholics how would
a Catholic ever vote for Joe Biden when
there's actually an assault on Catholics
I mean I don't know how many Catholics
or who's a Catholic in this room
how would any it is New Hampshire so
there was that one guy who clapped buddy
as a Catholic because specifically
Catholics are targeted by the FBI and
the doj
and then you're supposed to vote for Joe
Biden it doesn't make sense I will
direct a completely overhauled doj to
investigate every radical district
attorney and
an AG and a d a okay attorney generals
all over the country it's Attorneys
General Sir they're attorneys they're
not generals they're crooked as hell a
lot of them are really bad all right so
anyway there's no evidence that Joe
Biden is going after Catholics it's
idiotic Joe Biden aside from the fact
that Joe Biden is Catholic now you could
be Catholic and go after Catholics aside
from that Joe Biden also isn't doing it
Trump then re rehashing his uh rants
about uh appliances staying away from
the third element of the bathroom here
sometimes Trump becomes fixated on
toilets he didn't in this clip but he is
very much obsessed with washing machines
and dryers oh they want to take away
your your guest stoves does anybody like
gas better you cook a lot more than I do
I just switched to induction I have to
tell you it is phenomenal I did salute
my gas stove as they took it away though
and I I was crying
because I have a lot of friends that are
really into the cooking thing and they
say yes it's better so but they want to
take it away they want to take away your
washing machines and your dryers
they don't want to give you any water
for the washing machine even though you
have so much water you don't know what
the hell to do with it up here it flows
out into the ocean now they want to take
away your yeah
you can have
my induction cooktop when you pry it
from my cold dead hands Joe Biden by the
way in all honesty induction is really
fantastic I couldn't recommend it more
Trump again is trying to wrap the
audience into being shared victims with
his indictment he's come up with this
line he's using it in those grifty
fundraising emails he's using it in
interviews he says when they indicted me
they really indicted you which is of
course not true they indicted him
Democrats Marxist Communists and
fascists indict me I consider it a badge
a great great beautiful badge of honor
and courage
remember that there is no evidence of
marxist prosecutors right now
because I'm being dated for you
Democrats Marxist communists
this has just gotten so dumb where you
know maybe the reason the crowd is dead
is they've heard this stuff a million
times I once went to a great I've told
the story before I went to a Billy Joel
concert and Billy Joel came out and said
I don't have any new stuff to play for
you and the crowd went absolutely wild
because everybody wants to hear the hits
with Trump he's been giving the same
speech for three and a half years at
this point no we've all heard it a
million times we know the trans swimmer
you don't like the trans swimmer and you
showed Abdul a picture of your house
we've heard it a million times here's
Trump talking about Rhonda Santos we
have clips of Ron where he had a closed
State we will close our state we will he
was closed now he says oh we're so open
he wasn't open there were some Governors
like Henry McMaster because I didn't
make anybody close it was a federalist
program the Democrats all close some
Governors closed some Governors closed
for a short time Georgia was closed a
little bit for a short time they did a
very good job
um it was a little bit closed it's sort
of like you're a little bit pregnant is
this the state is somewhat closed oh
really wow that's interesting South if
you look at South Dakota
Christy did a very good job she was open
she kept it open
and some others they did a very good job
but Ron was actually strongly close
remember he closed the beaches closed
the highways he didn't want anybody on
everybody locked in he would make very
threatening speeches you know I think
he's a tough guy and uh but then all of
a sudden he's campaign I didn't close I
didn't close and the at the media the
face I have to tell you I I have I found
no evidence that Ron DeSantis closed the
highways I'm not aware of any any state
that closed highways I may be wrong and
I will correct it at the start of the
show tomorrow but closed highways not
making sense Trump claims that CNN's
failed former CEO Chris Licht was fired
because they had a trump Town Hall that
got great ratings which is very stupid
why would you do why would you fire a
guy for great ratings with The
Apprentice what do you think how
important in other words how important
was The Apprentice yeah no okay
no okay I don't know I think I'm not
insulted by that she says
all right well it's uh just a little
rumor that goes around they blame this
guy Jeff Zucker who got fired at CNN
zuga I got him his job and then he got
fired but it took too long to fire him
how about CNN we did the CNN Town Hall
did anybody see it
so it was a ratings Bonanza for them I
did it because I was going into enemy
territory but to get lousy ratings and
so I'm sure there goes their camera just
the camera just went off
who cares
their camera just went off
it didn't the little red light and all
of a sudden what happened to that red
light but you know what so CNN they get
started walking and they they I could
see the level of hostility was
incredible but think of it they fired
the head of CNN
and he had the highest rated show at 11
years it is not true that Trump's Town
Hall was the highest rated show in 11
years they fired him because the entire
CNN apparatus has had like 40 50 reduced
ratings which is a nightmare and then
lastly Trump capping off this completely
unhinged speech by saying how can they
arrest me if I'm a candidate the
candidates can't get arrested apparently
but they are fighting me they even tried
to have me arrested
I'm a candidate I said wait a minute I'm
a candidate you're arresting a candidate
yeah because you're leading that's why
we're arresting well it's because you uh
appear to have committed crimes and so
this is another story when Trump gets
arrested it's an arrest of all of his
followers metaphorically and the reason
they arrested him was because he's
leading the Republican primary which of
course makes no sense because DeSantis
does better against Joe Biden in general
election polling why would you try to
hurt the campaign of the guy that you
are more likely to be able to defeat in
November of 2024 it doesn't make any
sense my friends folks after the break
I am going to play for you maybe one of
the most insane clips of the Year okay
so stay with us make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube it's free it's
free listen Howard Stern said yesterday
he doesn't subscribe even though he
watches okay so when I say this there's
three million people around watching and
not subscribing Howard Stern is one of
those people okay hit that subscribe
button let's get to 2 million let's do
it quick break and write back
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
all right this one I hope you're sitting
down for or or at least braced or
attached to something because this is
like nothing I have ever seen just when
it seems as though there is nowhere else
to go there is no place to hide for
Donald Trump now that this audio tape
has come out where Trump is clearly
heard shuffling papers and saying these
are secret documents these are
classified documents I can't show you
the stuff I shouldn't be showing you
this stuff Trump was interviewed
yesterday after his speech in New
Hampshire by the publication semaphore
and Trump's new claim is he wasn't
actually holding up any documents it was
just like golf related documents
uh yeah he's you can hear him shuffling
papers he's saying these are secret
documents but there weren't actually any
documents he was just playing it up look
at this article this is by Shelby
Talcott for semaphore it was bravado
Trump says he wasn't holding up
classified documents in the 2021 meeting
referred to on the tape
look at these quotes I would say it was
bravado if you want to know the truth it
was bravado Trump said in an interview a
board is playing with semaphore and ABC
News I was talking and just holding up
papers and talking about them but I had
no documents I didn't have any documents
um the late the latest comments
suggested a new potential legal argument
from Trump that he was overselling the
material he was showing to an aide and
people working on a biography of Mark
Meadows in a recording quote I just held
up a whole pile of my desk is loaded up
with papers I have papers from 25
different things he said adding he kept
relevant news articles about topics like
Iran on hand at one point Trump gestured
to the seat next to him on the plane
were a stack of various papers
newspapers copies of a speech printouts
of article sat he grabbed some from the
pile and placed them in front of him
moving the route moving them around as
he spoke and offering up a physical
reenactment of what he said was
occurring on the audio tape did I use
the word plans what I'm referring to is
magazines newspapers plans of buildings
I had plans of buildings you know
building plans I had plans for a golf
course asked if he had any regrets about
his handling of classified documents
Trump said no
no I have no regrets I didn't have a
classified document there was no
classified document on my desk
wow
um this is like nothing I've ever seen
or heard of the here's the new position
yes Trump does refer to documents on the
audio recording yes you hear papers
shuffling around yes there were papers
on Trump's desk and yes Trump uses the
word plans but these were not classified
plans to attack Iran
these were Golf Course plans for for a
golf course Trump planned to build and
he was just trying to impress the people
around him now of course the problem is
there are witnesses who have testified
that these really were documents related
to military plans and defense
information that's a little bit of a
problem it may be a problem if Trump
tries to use this argument in court
um and of course the other problem is
that this is explanation number seven or
eight for the exact same thing there
were classified documents but they were
Declassified oh there were classified
documents but I had the right to have
them and they are de facto Declassified
just by virtue of me having them oh
there were no documents at all there
were papers but they weren't classified
documents there were classified
documents but I didn't take them the FBI
planted them or there might have been
some documents and boxes along with
clothes and mementos as these people
call them I don't know why they say
momentos instead of the word mementos
they just make up words I don't know uh
but it's it's just completely crazy now
I want to add one other commentary here
and I think that this is an important
thing to mention
there are some people on the
Revolutionary left I I know that some
people call them tankies I'm trying to
be as least pejorative as possible the
the sort of like pro-putin left the
Revolutionary left the folks who like
Maduro and Venezuela or Castro or these
types of folks there are some on the
Revolutionary left who are saying this
is I'm not even going to name names this
is this entire leaked audio recording
story is another example of the
corporate media
ignoring the good things about Trump
these plans to attack Iran Trump didn't
want to attack Iran I got a few emails
about this from revolutionary left to
saying David why won't you be honest and
tell the real story the real story is
the media hates Trump because when he
was given that plan to attack Iran he
didn't want to do it now there's a whole
bunch of different things that could be
said including that presidents are
presented with every option all the time
and the idea that someone was pushing
him to attack Iran and he didn't want to
do it we don't even know that to be true
but you have to remember Trump has no
idea what he's for or against he might
be for or against attacking Iran today
he might have been for or against
attacking Iran on the day that he was
presented with those plans or on the day
that he showed someone it doesn't matter
Trump doesn't know anything about Iran
he doesn't know anything about foreign
policy it is irrelevant to whether Trump
committed the crimes for which he's been
arrested whether on that day or on the
day before or on the day after
he wanted to attack Iran or not and the
Revolutionary leftists who are saying
there's no story here other than Trump
really was against Wars and he was
against war with Iran you were just flat
out wrong that is not the story here the
story here is they've got Trump dead to
rights on an audio recording committing
the exact crimes that he's been charged
for now what is his lawyer saying about
it let's talk about that next Alina Haba
one of Trump's so-called lawyers again
we never know like who's a TV lawyer
who's an actual lawyer representing
Trump in court it seems Alina Haba at
one point was actually representing
Trump in some legal capacity she
completely screwed up appears to have
lied horrible just horrible now she
seems to have shifted to being more of a
TV lawyer she went on Fox News and good
for him Lawrence Jones I've been
critical of Lawrence Jones on Fox News
before he actually confronts her with
the question that on the one hand Trump
says that the documents were
Declassified on the other hand he told
Brett Baier the documents were
classified but that that's okay then
he's saying there's no documents what is
the truth and try lawyer Alina habit
says I don't know I don't know what the
truth is
so is it the position of the president
that when he was having that
conversation the information that he was
talking about was already Declassified
or was it what he told Brett Baird that
it was a news article there or is it
either or or is it both I don't know and
here's what I do know the clip they put
out doesn't answer that question all it
says is President Trump said hi look if
I was President I can declassify a
classified document and when you're not
president you can't only the president
he was simply in Fort with with
absolutely no personal stake in it
whatsoever Trump was merely informing
the people around him about how
classification works that's all why is
everybody getting all worked up as if
there's some problem here do that what
does that say well it says exactly what
dual system of justice we're living in
that's what I heard that's what I saw
and I would and and by the way all we
know tapes isn't that the best and by
the way didn't she get the update from
the semaphore article we just looked at
where now Trump says there were no
documents that's the new line there
simply were no documents whatsoever and
of course as you know and we're putting
the transcript up on the screen Trump
says the document is top secret on the
recording Trump says it's highly
confidential and secret this is secret
information so he knows that it is now
the new argument they're saying is
that is a Lie the transcript is of trump
lying that those are classified secret
documents which is just absolutely
amazing another clip from this interview
with Trump's pseudo lawyer Alina Haba
um again just going in circles uh she
says in the indictment they don't
mention an Iran document and then the
question is well have they found the
document Trump may have destroyed that
document Trump's flushing documents all
these things and she says well it
doesn't even matter because it's a lie
anyway that the document was there if
you're confused about what I'm telling
you right now it's because it's this
confusing uh
that in the indictment itself there was
no Iran documents named as part of it
just want the American public to realize
that that document that they claim he
had was not part of the indictment
possibly because he didn't turn it over
possibly because it was destroyed this
is desperate times and Desperate
Measures by people that are founding
that's what they're saying it was but
that was not part of the indictment it
doesn't make sense because it's a lie
they are just trying to distract the
American remember Alina have a lies all
the time if anybody here is almost
certainly lying it's her well that's the
that's the game right now in America
it's
what I know the president wants to bring
back to this country we haven't seen it
since 2020 when he left but hopefully
we'll see it again in 2024 when he wins
yeah there you go that's a very
optimistic spin or maybe we'll see it
during the trial the trial is of course
the opportunity to put out all of those
facts and legal arguments the problem is
that the vast majority of the legal
arguments they're telegraphing that they
might use this was not actually a
criminal thing it's a presidential
records act thing well that's not the
that's a misstatement of the law and and
no serious judge would even allow that
argument to be made to a jury well he
was just lying about having the
documents okay well that's really hard
to believe at this point given
everything else that's been said this is
really an indicative situation of panic
panic at the end of the day and if
you're just listening today we'll have
all these clips we're playing on our
Instagram
on our Tick Tock and of course on the
YouTube channel
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the mayor of Miami Francis Suarez who is
running for the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination currently
polling
0.0 has made what could be a critical
critical error which is when he was
asked about the uyghur people this is
the Muslim ethnic minority in China that
is very much discriminated against that
we've talked about before he had no idea
what it was and actually joked what is
it called a Weeble and it is cringe but
the upshot of all of this is I don't
think it'll really hurt his campaign in
the sense that he's already polling zero
this was during an interview with Hugh
Hewitt here is Francis Suarez making the
argument that he has what it takes so
listen if you're the mayor of Miami
ostensibly you don't need to know much
about the weaker people you could say
well he still should because there might
be refugees in Miami okay all right but
it's a bit of a stretch okay you don't
need to know about the uyghur people to
be a good administrator of the city of
Miami if you're making the case that
you're ready to be president of the
United States you at least have to be
aware of what Hugh Hewitt is talking
about if you're averse to cringe you
probably want to skip the following 12
seconds of audio and video will you be
talking about the uyghurs in your
campaign
the uyghurs
what's a wiener okay we'll come back to
that uh
I love Hugh Hewitt going well we'll come
back to that later uh yeah he might be
someone might be able to pass him a note
during the remainder of the interview
dear God and then uh here at the end of
the interview Suarez acting like he's
going to take it very seriously and look
into it but he said what was it is that
the Weebles he gave me homework uh you
I'll look at what I was it would you
call it a Weeble the wiggers you really
need to know about the uyghurs mayor you
got to talk about it every day okay I
will I will talk about I will vote I
will search uyghurs I'm a good learner
um this is really bad and you know the
truth is uh you know when I look at the
list of people who are running and by
the way as I told you
I have a new poll from morning consult
Suarez is polling zero but it's like a
super strong zero it's probably close to
one I mean when I say he's polling 0.0
it's probably more like 0.9 or something
like that
um he's already polling zero so what of
these candidates who would have
something substantive to say about the
uyghur people Trump probably not
DeSantis maybe Pence would know
something about them ramaswamy he could
probably talk about the uyghur people
but it would make no sense Nikki Haley I
think May would be the person who could
most coherently talk about the uyghur
people
um Chris Christie could I don't know
about Tim Scott the point here is
I think Suarez may be alone and not even
having heard of the uyghur people
but
most of these candidates would have very
little that is substantive to actually
say now as a reminder the uyghurs are a
Muslim ethnic group
um native to and I know my pronunciation
is not good
xinjiang China
uh and they have their own culture and
language they face significant
repression by the Chinese government
persecution I've recommended a couple of
books about this we've done at least one
interview about it and China is accused
of committing crimes against humanity uh
and even genocide against the uyghur
people in xinjiang and it is a major
geopolitical issue this is another
example of how these right-wingers who
say I guess I'll run for president they
really aren't ready for this it reminds
me of the Gary Johnson moment where he
was asked what would you do about Aleppo
and he goes Aleppo what's Aleppo that
category what would you do if you were
elected about Aleppo about Aleppo and
what is Aleppo
you're kidding no
Aleppo is in Syria
okay now fortunately for Gary Johnson
his campaign was also Dead on Arrival
so the Damage Done by that moment was
was limited to say the least
very very bad and um you know for all
the criticisms of the people running
against Joe Biden that I've had I think
if you ask Bobby Kennedy Jr about the
uyghur people he's going to have
something for you and if you ask
Marianne Williamson about uh the uyghur
people she is also going to have
something for you it might be well we
need love we need love for the uyghur I
don't know what it would be but
um she would have something that would
make more sense than Francis Suarez so
polling zero and probably not gonna go
much higher after yesterday's disastrous
interview with Hugh Hewitt and by the
way good for Hugh Hewitt it for saying
you're kidding right you got to know
about this this is something you have to
know about uh we'll come back to that
maybe the funniest line ever uttered by
Hugh Hewitt on the radio there is a
prosecutor who is saying the Trump tape
is game over we've heard a lot from
Trump about the tape and Trump says the
tape's fine the tape does nothing it was
illegally leaked we should go after
whoever leaked it and also I did
everything fine I did everything right
and they indicted me As Trump likes to
say well actual legal professionals say
that this is a very very very bad
development for the failed former
president former prosecutor on new Trump
tape quote this is game over this is
Andrew Weissman he says that
um uh the public should remember
that uh the prosecutors for special
counsel Jack Smith have had the tape of
trump discussing the documents before it
was publicized that they've likely
interviewed everyone in the room except
for Trump himself and that it would
allow prosecutors to have all accounts
of what happened while Trump was
speaking this is a critical uh a fact to
understand
Trump's new argument is okay I shuffled
papers around but I wasn't really
showing anybody the classified
classified documents I was pretending to
be showing it was bravado I have stacks
of papers on my desk
as Andrew Weissman former prosecutor
points out
everybody who was in the room has
probably already said oh I saw what it
was and if indeed it was a plan to
attack Iran from General mark milley
that's already in evidence and that's
going to be a real problem for Donald
Trump uh Weissman goes on to tell
Lawrence O'Donnell quote so the big
picture here I think for people is this
is game over if you were following the
facts and the law
um again on the recording Trump heard
discussing classified information about
a potential plant attack on Iran
Weissman says Trump isn't charged with
dissemination of National Defense
information only that he continued to
possess it but that could be proven and
the tape is absolutely clear that's
another really important question very
often when defendants or their lawyers
attempt to try cases in the media first
for public opinion benefit they will
make
arguments in defense of themselves or
their clients that aren't actually
related to what you have been charged
with
Trump's argument I didn't really show
anybody that particular document is not
a defense to what Trump has been charged
with it's sort of like if you say hey uh
DUI we're charging with DUI and I go I
didn't have any stolen property in the
car I had everything that was in the car
was my own it was my phone and it was my
you know whatever
well fine but you're charged with DUI
not with having stolen stuff in the car
and that is essentially what is
happening Happening Here Andrew Weissman
going on to say quote this is a question
now of Simply will the government get a
trial before the general election will a
jury actually follow the law and the
facts and will the electorate follow the
facts and care that's what this is
really about uh absolutely correct
Weitzman added that the tape is only one
piece of a massive mountain of evidence
against Trump trump claimed after the
tape was publicized that it exonerates
him but it appears to show him
recognizing how the classification
process works and that he was continuing
to hold on to uh National Defense
information I will say
we've heard these announcements of
Trump's inevitable demise many times
before and I agree that this is
different we now have multiple arrests
possibly a third and fourth arrest
coming we have a mountain of evidence we
have pictures trumps toilets surrounded
by documents it's it's unbelievable
stuff we've never seen anything like
this in American history that being said
I like to err on the side of caution and
so I am not making any premature
announcements of Trump's demise I've
learned enough times not to do that but
yes the tape is really really
really bad and uh I can only imagine
that there will be some people around
Trump actually saying you don't want to
go to trial with this you actually
should take a plea deal whether
anybody's going to be able to convince
Donald Trump to do that that's a
different question and I certainly can't
answer at this point that the answer is
yes
if you value what we do at the day the
department show remember to support us
on patreon go to patreon.com
davidpackman show where you can get
access to behind the scenes videos The
Daily bonus show the commercial free
Daily Show as well as special discounts
on merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpackman show
alright this is a really great thing
Howard Stern is a big fan of the David
packman show there was like a 10 minute
segment on yesterday's Howard Stern Show
where he basically just sang the Praises
of the show and it's just such a great
thing so many of you I know also watch
or listen to the Howard Stern Show many
of you know that I've been in Howard's
audience since I was like 14 my mom
would be driving me to high school and
I'd listen to the seven minutes of the
show that I could in the the car on the
way and
I have always been wondering would there
be anything that I could do on the show
that would get me on the radar of the
Howard Stern Show
and I didn't really do anything other
than just doing the show and it turns
out Howard is a fan check this out this
is very cool but I will tell you there
is something not so cool in this which
we're going to get to in a moment but
check this out so many of you writing to
me yesterday about it you ever watched
this guy on the internet
his name is uh David packman you ever
see him
no I've heard that name though what is
what is here I don't know I don't know I
I have a YouTube uh subscription so I
just watch different things on YouTube
and this he seems like he's a kid I
don't know how old he is I love that I
mean that that I that is maybe the best
part of the entire thing I love that I
seem like a kid but he looks like a kid
lately to me but he's like a young guy
and he he talks politics he's like a
commentator and he's really good and I'm
just wondering who he is and what he's
done I I end up watching everything he
does
folks folks I think you can subscribe to
his channel absolutely which I don't do
like I don't pay for it I get the free
feed oh you got to be kidding me Howard
do you give him a like or anything do
you do anything I don't give anybody any
likes I don't like anything but I do
like the guy just not giving a like
that's so dumb like give me likes we
need those likes though please
I have friends who are really into like
how come you didn't like my this or that
and I go oh I don't know I I mean I like
it but I don't have to tell the world I
like it this is this is very very good
stuff like this is really a great great
thing for the show and I'll tell you
there are some really
big people that listen to the Howard
Stern Show every day and I've heard from
some of them over the last 24 hours this
is really a big deal for the show I end
up putting on YouTube and I watch
different clips either about Chess or
but this guy David Pac-Man shows up
and he's like a commentator like you'd
see they should really hire him on MSNBC
MSNBC doesn't want me now that's a whole
other story like every single one of
these little Clips could be a whole
conversation I've been on Fox news I've
been on CNN I've been on serious
satellite radio I've been yeah I have
never been on MSNBC MSNBC doesn't want
me they're not interested in what I have
to offer that's very very clear oh David
Pac-Man's 39 years old oh he looks like
he's 15 to me I'll take it like a 15
year old and he's 39 dude I thought he
was like a um I thought he was like a uh
like a high school student or someone
who's particularly bright if if I was
doing what I was doing as a high school
student it would be an unbelievable
thing I would love that I would love to
go back and do it as a high school
student
so now he's a 40 year old guy he's just
you know he's like everybody else
nobody's very good I mean by the way
he's not paying for this uh mention I
just I just was wondering if you watched
him I was thinking about him he
the guys just told me he has 1.7 million
subscribers on YouTube really should be
two million so well that's nice I'm sure
he can make a living doing that true
yeah no it's not bad uh let's just look
at a couple other this I can't tell
everybody how much I enjoyed listening
to this yesterday we were every that we
were just all listening to this
well I don't know you know it seems to
me the part that I see is free and then
it says well if you want to be a paid
subscriber and like hear the rest of his
content you could pay and I'm like yes I
just like the free content I need well
he's got 1.7 million of those yeah I'm
subscribers yeah but I think they're
like me they're Cheapskates who won't
pay for Content sadly 99.3 I don't want
to say Cheapskates they're just they're
not paying that's Howard is not wrong
yeah a David Pac-Man membership cost 60
bucks a month I'm not I'm not getting
started with that I don't even know how
to send them six bucks you know what I
mean I don't even like know how to do
all that folks
we're failing through your YouTube
subscription you've got you know you
filled out everything there you can buy
it in app you know all right I don't
want it
damn it he doesn't want the bonus show
folks oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad
free version
but anyway
you'll take a little of him you don't
need a lot yeah you know I got enough of
him
but he's very good and he like he sits
there and he talks about politics too I
generally agree with everything he's
saying
folks that is big hair because I mean
you already think what he thinks
well I love the way he articulates it
thank you this is this is I can't think
of anything better than this there's
just a couple I hope people are enjoying
this there's just a couple more of these
okay so why do I watch David Pac-Man or
Rachel manners I like to find people who
I still feel like they have a grip on
reality you need a group to to yeah it
makes me feel better Community this is
what I'm talking about that we need on
the left because I'm sitting at home
thinking maybe I'm out of my mind yes
I mean this is way worse than whatever
they were accusing Hillary of doing with
our emails true and yet nobody seems to
be upset about it right it's so so
anyway I'm not here even to I'm sick of
uh sitting and talking about Trump and
this and that the other thing but
I just that's I like this guy that's all
my point is he seems to be very
articulate you need to be uh validated
yeah and I think if you disagree with me
and everything I just said watch this
guy Pac-Man he's good Pac-Man he's
Pac-Man
incredible I mean that's how can you say
it's Pac-Man that is why I watch
people who think like me
and David Pacman thinks like me and I I
was just curious who this guy is and
where he comes from because I I I'm an
admirer of his broadcast incredible well
now you know he's been around a while
then maybe you can look up his
background he's not still in high school
right he probably went to college true
you can look him up
really inferring a lot of important
stuff I listened to David packman
because I found this guy on YouTube
who is has a very easy way of describing
what is going on thank you and you watch
it and it makes a lot of sense he's not
he's dealing in facts
and I like them that's all I don't know
who the guy is I don't know where he
came from I don't know well I'm glad to
explain it all and lastly here's a funny
thing a guy calls in to say What about
Brian Tyler Cohen and Howard's like I
don't know about that and by the way we
love Brian I was texting with Brian
yesterday and at first when people wrote
to me and said he's talking about both
of you guys I wrote to Brian and I said
hey apparently Howard's talking about
both of us then I heard it and this was
the mention of Brian we were laughing
about it uh Jerry you're on the air in
Maryland Howard Howard how are you doing
I've been listening to you since uh DC
101 way back when uh and I feel your
pain about uh about Trump and everything
I I didn't call you for this reason but
if you're into Pac-Man there's also
Brian Tyler Cohen very similar guy he's
got a show also on YouTube he has a
couple million viewers too yeah there's
another guy I do watch I don't but but
Pac-Man I like the best outfit I like
Pac-Man too very intelligent and he yes
who is that who is Pac-Man by the way
all right so anyway we reached out and
we said if Howard wants to know the
oranges story of Pac-Man I'm glad to be
on this is fantastic so that this is
just a great thing it's a great thing
for the show you know whatever you think
about Howard Stern as an interviewer
absolutely Top Notch essentially created
the medium and format that allows shows
like mine to exist I know a lot of
people talk about Rush Limbaugh did this
and that and the other no no no no no no
uh really the sort of like Community
conversational uh format that I believe
all of these shows are based on
and the idea that it is something people
would engage with I think Howard Stern
is single-handedly responsible for
creating that so this is a great thing
and in all seriousness by the way you
know I know we're joking around about
Howard won't pay for the bonus show the
David Pac-Man membership costs six bucks
a month there you go in all seriousness
it's emblematic of what we're up against
what Howard did yesterday is worth much
more than six bucks a month to the show
but nearly billionaire Howard Stern
loves the content uh among all the
things that he could watch among
everything he has to do he could be
hanging out with Billy Joel right uh and
he's watching the David Pacman show and
he won't get a membership so it's not a
criticism of Howard but this is the
uphill battle we're up against on the
right some right-wing Rich dude stumbles
across Ben Shapiro one time sends five
million bucks and says use this money to
run Facebook ads and then they do it and
then they grow the right has that
the left is different so at a minimum
okay when Howard Stern says I love the
content but I won't subscribe for six
bucks the minimum you can do is hit the
Subscribe button on YouTube help us get
to that 2 million and if you can in all
seriousness go to joinpackman.com get
yourself a membership you can use the
coupon code indicted again and uh what
what a day what a day all right before
we move on to voicemails and other
things I do want to just close the loop
on this Arc that we've looked at today
the leaked Trump audio recording Trump
telling semaphore I didn't actually have
documents I was referring to Alina Haba
Trump's lawyer saying in an interview we
don't even really know anything about
anything ever uh Donald Trump imploding
in an all capital letters rant on Truth
social
where he said quote if I wasn't running
for president or if I was losing badly
in the polls I am winning by record
number prison against Biden also I would
never have been fake indicted of course
the indictments are very real likewise
if the very corrupt Democrats truly
wanted to run against me I wouldn't have
been indicted it is all a badge of honor
and courage I am being indicted for you
nothing in that screed makes any sense
whatsoever the indictment is real it has
nothing to do with corrupt Democrats it
has nothing to do with Joe Biden it has
nothing to do with Trump's polling
whatsoever Trump continuing please
remember that the only reason I was
indicted election interference is
because the Democrats don't want to run
against me actually they do you're
polling worse than DeSantis why wouldn't
they want to run against you they
weaponized the doj and FBI I am beating
crooked Joe Biden in virtually every
poll that is untrue DeSantis is beating
him but you're not and easily beat him
in the last election but the election
was rigged this is untrue Joe Biden won
in 2016 it was the same thing
spewed from the mouths of the same
failed pundits and losers they said I
couldn't beat Hillary how did that work
out Doug Shone of Fox News should get a
new playbook and then lastly talking
about his visit in uh in New Hampshire
three people in New Hampshire asked me
why Fox News uses such horrible pictures
of me when doing or promoting a story
I'm sure they were crying right the
coloring distortions everything are just
so bad they must sit and look at 100
different shots and then take the 10
absolute worst my staff has even
complained about it for months but the
no avail folks this is the guy who
criticizes others for being snowflakes
and triggered who doesn't like the
pictures they're using of him on Fox Fox
is just bad news he goes on to say but
I'm leading in the polls by record
numbers so perhaps their bull is just
not working they are down 37 percent for
a reason Trump is crumbling there's no
other way to say it Trump is crumbling
he doesn't know what argument to make at
this point in time none of the arguments
are working they're all lies they don't
make sense they're not legal arguments
we can only hope
and remember this isn't me going we can
only hope he gets life in prison we can
only hope
that Justice transpires
that's called Law and Order we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P
people are calling in because of the
story I told on the bonus show about my
flight back from San Francisco
and people are criticizing me even
though I was the victim
of Pricks on my flight take a listen
Davis Alan from Jersey and I was
listening to the bonus show yesterday
and you were telling another story of
your airline travel yeah and all these
airline travel stores you tell are
exactly the same thing I've told like
two stories you're the only one that
knows the procedure to get to your
senior the only one that knows the right
time to put the window shade up the
right time to put the windows shade down
the proper procedure to get your bag in
the overhead bin you're the only one
that knows how to do the roller bag and
the personal item everybody else is
doing it wrong David you're the only one
or perhaps David
in these situations in these situations
you should step back and say am I the
only one that knows how to put the bags
in the overhead bin am I the only one or
perhaps everybody else is doing it the
right way and you're doing it the wrong
way David I'm the problem clearly think
about this David because it can't be
that everybody else is always wrong and
doing it the wrong way all right listen
dude I told one story in 2021 on a
Lufthansa flight from Frankfurt to JFK
in which I explained that there was a
particular guy okay this was a 747 out
of 400 people there was one guy who
yelled at me because I used an overhead
bin okay all the other 399 people on the
flight did the right thing it's not
everybody's doing it wrong and I'm doing
it right I then have had 10 flights
since then where nobody's done anything
wrong and last week on my flight back
from San Francisco
one guy jumped ahead of me pushed his
way past me to cram his bag into the
obvious spot where I was about to lift
my bag
there were 180 people on that flight 179
of them including my daughter all
behaved perfectly
it's not everybody's doing everything
wrong get out of here give me a break
dude okay we've got a great bonus show
for you today
the Supreme Court is putting some first
amendment limits on laws that ban online
threats why what are those limits we're
going to discuss it there is a Delaware
City that is going to give corporations
the right to vote in elections what yes
and lastly a Republican senator is
challenging a union leader to a mixed
martial arts fight at least it's for
charity all of it we are going to talk
about on the bonus show a David Pac-Man
membership costs six bucks a month true
but with a discount code it's only two
you can use the discount code indicted
again and we will have such a great
bonus show for you today we will see you
then otherwise I will be back here
tomorrow if I have anything to say about
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's springtime
you're outside more it is time for
sunscreen but stay away from the
chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below